[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine je vais faire quelque
chose d'un petit peu différent je veux
vraiment encourager les gens qui
écoutent cette chronique à aller voir
laissez-nous raconter une série qui a
été réalisée par qui enquête épisode qui
a commencé à être diffuser le 19
novembre et ça a été produit par terre
et nous et pourquoi je veux que vous
ayez le voir si le genre de Siri que
j'ai je rêve d'avoir en français qui
vient de la communauté autochtone
francophone au Québec mais aussi
anglophone parce qu'on n'est pas
uniquement
limité par qui nous a colonisé au Québec
je veux qu'on aille la voir parce que il
y a eu un travail d'amour derrière cette
série quatre ans puis surtout dans une
période un peu compliqué
je pense 30 communautés visiter des
milliers de kilomètres de parcourus mais
pour avoir une voix qui est entendue de
différentes communautés de différentes
personnes
c'est comme le travail ou est-ce que je
veux qu'on ouvre la porte et qu'on voit
toutes les figures qui devraient dans
les médias qui devraient dans les
nouvelles théorème dans les émissions
mais qu'on a encore beaucoup de travail
à faire pour faire valoriser dans les
médias traditionnels et aussi ce qui est
très différent si que quand un média ou
une maison de production comme père et
nous fait un travail justement auprès
des communautés il y a un travail de
relations qui doit être bâtie et ce
travail de relation là se voit dans ce
documentaire là pourquoi un travail de
relation pourquoi pas juste faire le
documentaire enregistrer quelqu'un qui
est volontaire à parler bien c'est parce
que s'exposer dans les médias quand on
est autochtone c'est s'exposer la
discrimination parfois à des
commentaires à de la critique on n'est
pas encore dans un espace sécuritaire
quand on est autochtone pour que notre
culture et ce qu'on a à dire soit vu
d'une manière égalitaire et je vous le
dis tout de suite c'est vraiment pas
une série comme on dit sur la misère des
pop autochtones on sait nos défis aussi
les les circonstances dans l'histoire du
Canada qui ont donné cette effacement
justement de la place publique des gens
des communautés là ce qu'on veut faire
avec ce cumulateur c'est montrer
justement pourquoi on est fier d'être si
on est pourquoi on est d'accord fier de
dire qu'on est des peuples autochtones
des telles nations et 11 nations au
Québec plus de 52 communautés qu'en 30
de ces 52 communautés ont été visitées
je sais que tu as un bon documentaire
derrière ça donc quatre épisodes vous
pourrez les voir sur ici télé mais je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui ouvre
à visiter les 22 autres communautés à
ouvrir plus grand à voir et entendre des
voix qui sont malheureusement pas
toujours mis de l'avant mais cette série
le fait extrêmement bien et je veux
encourager les gens aller la voir cette
série c'est un cadeau que communauté
fond au reste du Québec alors je vous
souhaite une belle semaine puis je vous
dis de profiter de votre visionnement